♪ ♪ ♪
- Dans la campagne d'Oka,
à l'ouest de Montréal,
la nouvelle serre de
l'entreprise Les Jardins
de la Pinède est opérationnelle
depuis quelques semaines.
Elle a une superficie
de 52 000 pieds carrés et huitit
variétés de légumes y sont
actuellement cultivées.
MARIE-JOSÉE DAGUERRE, coproprio,
Les Jardins de la Pinède
- On a besoin d'untrès
tropical pour faire pousser
des aubergines, donc on a besoin
de chaleur, on a besoin
Josée Daguerre
vend des paniers bios depuis
six ans et compte aujourd'hui
800 clients qui, pour
la plupart, n'achetaient rien
en hiver. Grâce à la serre,
elle pense maintenant atteindre
1000 abonnés et elle pourra
leur offrir des produits variés
à l'année longue.
- Les gens veulent vraiment
connaître la provenance
des légumes, ils veulent avoir
aussi un produit de qualité
et un produit bon au goût.
Tous nos plants sont en plein
sol, donc on produit plusieurs
variétés dans la serre.
On a vraiment, je dirais,
la Cadillac, présentement,
des serres en bio.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Une Cadillac qui a coûté
: quatre millions de dollars.
Mais la moitié a été payée grâce
à des subventions de Québec.
- Si on n'avait pa
subventions en pleine période
de pandémie, on n'aurait pas pu
construire le comp
- Son entreprise fait partie
des 200 projets de serres
qui ont été financ
le ministère de l'Agriculture
depuis un an. Le MAPAQ,
fin 2020donnédonnédonnédonnédoné
comme objectif de doubler
les 123 hectares de cultures
serricolec d'ici cinq
ans. En 2021, 40 % de l'objectif
a déjà été atteint, soit une
superficente à tout
le Parc olympique de Montréal.
ANDRÉ LAMONTAGNE, ministre
u Québec
- On a encore un 140-150 projets
qui sont en analyse. Ça fait
14 mois qu'on a lancé
la stratégie, alors pour moi,
la réponse est là,
l'effervescence est là,
le milieu est organisé.
- Les trois quarts des nouveaux
projets permettront à de petits
agriculteurs de prolonger
leur saison de queis;is;is;is;i;
l'autre quart visera une
production à l'année.
Industries Harnois,
dans Lanaudière,  plus
gros fabricants de serres
en Amérique. 160 personnes
travaillent ici. L'entreprise
compte 3c
et elle est en pleine expansion.
PATRICE HARNOIS, PDG,
Les Industries Harnois inc.
- On a toujours eu une demande
croissante, mais là,
actuellement, on travaille
beaucoup, beaucoup sur le futur,
par exemple sur d'autres projets
potentiels. Les légumes de base
comme tomates et autres,
ça demeure populaire. Puis,
ce qu'on voit de plus en plu
c'est du légumes feuilles,
c'est des fines herbes,
des choses un petit peu plus
spécialisées.
- Cliente des Industries
l'entreprise
Ferme d'Hiver est en train
d'agrandir à Vaudreuil-Dorion.
Surprise quand on entre
dans ses installations : de frat
ici. L'agriculture verticale
permet d'optimiser
la production.
YVES DAOUST, fondateur et chef
des tech Ferme d'H Ferme d'H Fer
- La fraise offre la capacité
de produire en bonne quantité
et de vendre avec une marge
suffisamment grande pour
justifier la mise en place
de plusieurs fermes. Ça va
marcher, la serre d'hiver,
si le maraîcher fait
de l'argent!
- Les marges de profits,
déjà petites en agriculture,
sont réduites en hiver en raison
des coûts énergétiques élevésuf.
Mais Ferme d'Hiver a développé
une technologie pour diminuer
les coûts.
- Dans la serre, ici, on a
l'équivalent de 700 kilowatt
qui est grosso modo 700 plinthes
chauffantes qu'on aurait
à la maison chez nous, donc il
ferait très, très, trè
Il fallait gérer la chaleur.
- Les lumières sont refroidies
à l'eau, mais leur chaleur
est captée et redirigée vers
te, utilisée
par un maraîcher local.
ANDRÉ ST-DENIS, copropriétaire,
Les Serres Vaudreuil inc.
- Pour la serre ici, on pourrait
dire qu'on sauve un 90 % là
qu'on n'utilise plus en propane
qu'on prend en électricité.
L'électricité, c'est de
l'électricité qui sert
pour les lumières qu'on récupère
la chaleur, puis on chauffe
la serre avec ça. Produire
à l'année, ça nous permet
d'avoir un revenu plus stable
toute l'année, ça nous permet
de garder des employés
à l'année aussi.
- Ferme d'Hiver, qui a signé
un contrat avec les supermarchés
IqpHé/I vendre ses fraises
à des prix concurrentiels
en hiver, annoncera bientôt
un nouveau projet pour décupler
sa production.
- On importe 133 millions
de kilos par année de fraises,
fait que même si on va
en chercher admettons
13 millions de kilos,
ce qu'on essaie de faire
dans les trois prochaines
années, ça serait quand mê
juste 10 % de coupures
d'importations, t'sais.
- Les ventes en serres ont
totalisé 403 milli
au Québec en 2020. Le chiffre
est en constante progression.
- Augmenter l'autonomie
alimentaire, ça vient faire
en sorte
en demandent, ça se parle
partout sur le territoire!
- André Lamontagne demande
aux Québécois d'ac
de plus d'aliments du Québec
chaque semaine, ce qui injectera
un milliard de dollars de plus
dans l'économie de
Ici Jean-Sébastien Cloutier,
Radio-Canada, Mon